they say i'm nasty
we're trying to go to bed and then you
just
go on you this is my house
you all better start respecting me are
we clear
yeah
with kevin saying quote this isn't even
the worst of it oh you tell me no it's
fine it's fine no it's not fine k-fed
posted then deleted three videos of
brittany arguing with their sons when
preston was 12 and jayden was 11. i just
don't even know what to say with you i
was in shock but do these videos show
evidence of emotional abuse or every
parent struggle with a willful preteen
[Music]
[Applause]
i just can't sleep have you lost your
mind
i do care but i'm shocked i'm scared of
you because you're weird because you're
going through puberty i don't know what
to say but i do care more than you know
in one of the videos brittany and
preston argue over his phone being taken
away when he walked into an ice cream
store barefoot uh yeah i think your
phone should be gone
okay for a very long time uh yeah for
not wearing shoes yeah are you wanting
attention baby is that what you're
saying well apparently you keep
interrupting every sentence i say i
think you just care about yourself they
were like look i'm telling you this is
happening in a scathing statement to e.t
brittany's lawyer matthew rosengart
calls kevin's bombshell itv interview
and social post quote cruel bottom of
the barrel stuff adding the videos could
land him in court for violating cyber
harassment and cyber bullying statutes
are you sure you want a piece of me i
don't see any criminal or civil
ramifications coming out of this
it is possible she could go to family
court
and raise issues in terms of kevin
federline and his parenting and by the
way it doesn't make his children appear
in a good light either mom decides to
take it away for me not wearing shoes
[Music]
to me it seems like the kids are being
disrespectful
and she's responding kfed claims his
decision to post the videos was in
response to britney calling their boys
hateful on instagram yesterday quote i
cannot sit back and let my sons be
accused in this way
[Music]